(upbeat music)
(audience clapping)
(audience cheering)
- This is Bebe.
Meet Bebe.
- [Oliver] Nice to meet you.
- [Bebe] How are you?
- How are you doing?
- The crowd, damn, the
crowd's going crazy.
[Kelly] I know.
[Oliver] Yeah, I'll take it.
(audience cheering loudly)
- [Kelly] You're name was said
and that happened.
I was like, okay.
- I like it.
I, my fear was walking
out to utter silence
so this is much better.
Thank you.
- Oh my god. You're handsome
and then you walk out with that accent.
[Oliver] Ah, come on.
[Kelly] Okay. Okay.
- So you grew up in London, right?
- Yeah. London is home.
- I love London.
Especially at Christmas time.
- That's, so, that's
mainly when I go back.
- Okay. That's the best time.
- Yeah. It's beautiful there.
You know like, very
much, everybody gets into
the Christmas spirit.
- Oh my God.
- The lights. It's...
- Oh my God, the little Christmas markets.
- It's a good time to go.
- Yes.
- Have you been to
London at Christmas time?
- I love it.
- Do it.
Yeah. I was like, if you haven't,
but so you were the baby in the family?
I'm the baby in the family as well.
- Yes.
- So, did you and your brother go at it?
How close were y'all in age?
- He's three years older than me.
- That's close enough.
- So we're pretty close.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But we didn't really have anything
in common growing up.
- Oh.
- Like for example, now he's a scientist
and I'm this.
(Kelly laughing)
so you know.
- And you can play one.
- Yeah, sure well, yeah, yeah.
Don't know about how convincingly.
But yeah, so we were just
very different growing up.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
We didn't have a lot in common,
but as we've got older,
we've started to kind of bond a bit more
and you know just see
each other as people.
He recently had a baby.
I became an uncle for the first time.
- That's so exciting.
(audience clapping)
[Oliver] Thank you.
[Kelly] That's cool,
because you get to have fun with him
and then you go, "here you go."
Then you can just sleep.
Sure. I feel like around
applause is unwarranted there.
I didn't have to do
anything apart from exist.
- I know, but it's exciting.
- To become an uncle.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. It is.
But him and his wife did all the work.
- Yeah. Yeah.
Well done. Well done.
- But yeah. Yes. Well done.
Great job.
But yeah, I was a kid who
I always wanted it to be
about me.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I think there was one birthday,
must have been about like, I
was probably seven or eight.
So he's, you know, 10 or 11.
And my mom, bless us,
she would always bake us
these amazing cakes.
- Wow.
- And she made one of the
head of Where's Waldo?
Or where's Wally as we would say.
- Yeah.
And it's huge.
And wanting it to all be about me.
The day before his birthday,
I went to this cake
- No.
- And I like a beast.
Not even with like a knife.
I just took a bit like
off of his head. Right.
And panicked as you would
as a seven year old.
I hid the cake behind the couch
thinking that if nobody
sees it, maybe they'll just,
I don't know what there was no cake.
Mom, you didn't bake a cake.
You're crazy.
- Oh my God.
- Obviously had to eventually
[Kelly] Own it.
[Oliver] fess up to it.
- and yeah, we, we've
been rebuilding since.
- Did your Mom not lose her mind?
- I'm sure. Well, I never did it again so.
- I just pictured my reaction (laughs)
- So, I'm sure she lost
her mind enough where,
- [Kelly] Oh.
- never again did I steal the cake the day
before the birthday with my bare hands.
- Oh my gosh.
What a turd move.
(all laughing)
- So we're, you know, we're
on the road to recovery.
- You're passed it now.
- Yeah, yeah. I'm gonna be a better uncle
than I was brother.
- Okay. Congrats.
- That's, thank you so much.
- Good job.
Good on you.
- Growth.
- So your brother is actually here.
How were y'all together growing up?
- [Kelly] Uh oh
- [Oliver] Oh
- I would come home and
I would have, my Barbies
would be, there would be
no heads on my Barbies.
- Oh
- Yes.
- That's typical brother stuff.
- Did you check behind the couch?
(all laughing)
- I didn't, but next
time, I will next time.
- All right. Yeah.
- Flo, you look really
handsome on TV, by the way.
- I know.
(audience cheering)
- That's amazing though.
It's funny how you, when
you're kids, you know
you're just like this sometimes
and then you get older
and like life changes and then it's like
then you form a bond
that is unlike any other.
That's super cool.
- Yeah.
- I love when that happens.
Well, now you guys are in season six,
- Season six
- On 9 1 1.
Congratulations.
(audience cheering and clapping)
- Season six.
So, what's going on with Buck?
What's going on with your character?
- Yeah. He's had an up and down season,
so kind of at the beginning of the season
we found him getting a
bit ahead of himself,
thinking that he was ready to step
into the role of being interim captain.
When Peter Krause, who plays the captain,
was his character was going away
and he was told you're not there yet.
You're a little bit too
young and inexperienced
and you got some more life to live.
So, he's been living some life.
He's a sperm donor to some people
that were in his life.
He, which was a big change for him.
- Yeah, that's a big move. Yeah.
- And then he died, not the, not the me
- Buck died.
- Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
- Not the babe, anyway.
- Yes. Yep.
Got real dark for a minute.
- Yeah, yeah, real dark real quick.
- So I, yeah, the character
died for three minutes
struck by lightning.
- Yeah.
- And then was brought back to life and,
you know that kind of,
I would assume resets the way you...
- Yeah. Any kind of
major thing in your life
- View mortality. Right.
- Yeah.
- So he's in a process
of refinding himself
and still kind of trying to walk that path
towards being a better firefighter,
a better leader,
and a better friend to those in his life.